I think is that the they actually go to
sleep at nighttime so right now they're
sleeping over there so they don't even
know I'm right here waiting to you know
pick up their meat steal their weapons
and their food while I sleep there you
go devious so it looks like a stall
shape I don't know what do you call it
like house yeah they've got a
schoolhouse each their own okay
and then I don't know if I mentioned it
but oh well I should have done it right
I'm gonna hide it and we hide it so they
no more notice relax nothing to see here
okay so it looks like there's a
explosive in there too
you're gonna let them sleep peacefully
right yes right
oh no I didn't walk through this okay
there they're suspicious but they're
okay fine
uh find another way to blow them up just
get right in there oh there were big red
barrels which always means explosion
yeah okay did you use the long to do
that one but I just had a stage flight
oh wow hey you got the explosion oh
that's there's multiple ways to you know
solve the puzzles and enemies defeat
enemies so I just tried that yeah I was
just doing it I was initially making mr.
thinking on the fly and now you can
stole their treasure yeah great see so I
got the new soldiers broadsword which is
14 instead of 5 so you know just seeing
that screen they already helped while I
got that will help oh no I can't take it
so I have to change it'll all be ok for
me to it's ok we had our fun yeah
goodbye
just stay there Wiggly so yeah the guy
you killed was really powerful back
hablen so he dropped a really powerful
sword ten arrows don't sneeze on those
arrows meat look up at the stars in the
sky it's so pretty really sweet yeah
those will call me in this
sweet they have no idea what I'm trying
to do now they're gonna go into the Big
Sleep should be a natural transition so
I have a fire arrow and bow motto which
they use fire way so you know some
people might really like to just jump
into the battle and then try to give
them with a new sword and stuff but
sometimes like person like me if there's
no good battle I just like to be sneaky
and try to shoot like expletive out
there you want to quite the fact that
but cobbling seem to have an affinity
for sleeping next to highly flammable
bear I mean it only makes sense yes it
wasn't my fault there maybe not the
smartest monsters
it's always important to have enough
food so you can restore your health more
food the better
Oh call Blaine
change it to different one there's his
own friend I know but you used so many
different kinds of weapons so far and
this is just a small sampling of the
different kinds of weapons in the game
there's so many different many a choice
me which one to take oh these guys to
stare fine
he was gloating nice what a jerk
so I love that move that you can do when
you're when you're leaving and sort of
stuff
so whenever you're trying to jump off
from your higher cliff try to use the
arrow that you go into that mode where
you can kind of slow down the time so
you have a better time to kind of
concentrate and try to focus on where
this shoot it's really cool really good
yeah you can do that from really high up
- it's already epic so I as you might
have noticed that I use longabaugh and
arrow and I sometimes iron out all my
arrows so what I do is actually try to
pick up the ones my enemy dropped and
make sure I have enough you can kind of
taunt them to keep shooting at you the
dangerous game is it's cheap
they're playing right in their hands
okay I'm busy we respect that all the
different kinds of ways to play this
game all the way to here I saw the
Guardian so I kind of wanted to be there
make sure I get there before yeah anyone
watching the previous segment I told him
what's what yeah running running really
bad I think he got the point though he's
pretty terrified let me try it where is
it
I see Mike still follow it
there you go I believe in you chica
we're entering a new area here around Oh
he's waking up oh good morning he's
grumpy when he wakes up it's okay you
got what you got them out oh yeah that's
right do that first and it makes sure
yeah so this will give us a little
analysis of his hip points breakdown for
a table even you yeah
so one other thing you can do is to whip
then is actually you can throw the
weapon like that and one Oh it'll give
you a critical hit if he actually landed
on yeah yeah good way to get weapons
that are about to break it's up T so
speaking of freedom and weapons this is
one of the weirdest thing
I'm not right now and I have to okay
haha right the fire strategy yes is a
great creative strategy what it is
I think it'll ultimately get him keep
saying you can play this game however
you want
well I think we're actually running out
of time otherwise it would have got him
the world definitely wants to see